America hasn't produced a world chess
champion since the 1970s and the latest
candidate just fell short in London last
night Fabiana Cara Juana lost the title
series to the defending champion
champion Magnus Carlsen they were tied
after 12 intense matches so they had to
play to sudden death Mark Phillips was
there as sporting stare downs go this
was not ali-frazier
but in the heady world of chess this is
his heavyweight as it gets the reigning
undisputed unflappable world champ 27
year old Norwegian Magnus the iceberg
Carlsen and fighting out of Brooklyn New
York the Challenger 26 year old Fabiano
the human processor Cara Juana he stood
to be the first American world champ
since Bobby Fischer beat the Kremlin's
darling Boris Spassky in 1972 this match
didn't have a Cold War backstory but it
did have its own tensions tied after 12
games it would be settled by a series of
speed chest shootouts for fab ease
traveling fan club that was enough it's
a big deal
I mean it hasn't happened in 60 plus
years the u.s. is just like blowing up
with chess it might have been a bigger
explosion of Carlson wasn't unbeatable
at speed chess it's from CBS News did
you feel any extra pressure as the first
American in what decades to have a
chance at becoming world champion I mean
I felt a lot of pressure but I have I
don't think that I had added pressure
because because I was the first Malick
American Challenger in a long time I
mainly and exhausted
Kerra wanna says he hopes this
tournament has put chess back on the
American map he did take an evidently
invincible champion to the brink it was
fun while it lasted
Fabiano is definitely a hero to American
chess
put us on the map and is taking Magnus
click for closer to the wire than
anyone's ever done before
that being said America really loves a
winner and it doesn't quite have one yet
for CBS this morning Mark Phillips
London